- What the hell
were you doing?
You're three hours late!
- Dad, you don't understand.
The car was busted...
[car sputtering]
...so we had to shred.
- Why are your lips red?
Were you eating a snow cone?
- That’s a really good guess.
- What kind of adults
rollerblade?
- The police are here,
and they're saying
that you bought alcohol
for minors.
[beer can opening]
- Thanks, boys!
[siren squawking]
- In Europe,
the drinking age
is like, ten.
- The could have been European.
- What made you think
they were European?
- They had a certain
je ne sais quoi.
- I think one of them
was eating pain au chocolat.
- Guys, everyone thinks
we're losers,
but that's about to change.
I know where the treasure
of Foggy Mountain is.
- From when we were kids?
- We are looking at
a hundred mil.
- A hundred million dollars?
- It'd be like, I mean,
I know it's more than this,
but at least
a million dollars each.
- Significantly more.
- Way more than that.
- What are we waiting for?
- The cute guys
that came in earlier.
- I didn't see nobody cute.
The ginger looked like
colonial ghost,
glasses looked like
Tim Burton drew him.
And then the short one,
we probably wear
the same size bra.
- They had a treasure map
with like an X on it.
- We gon' steal that map.
- That is a full on hawk.
[hawk screeching]
- Hey, buddy.
- Traverse it!
Traverse the rock.
[screeching, screaming]
- Does it not know
it can fly?
- Why did it walk away
with an attitude?
- Everyone
is after this treasure.
- We deserve that.
- You deserve it?
- Yeah.
- Three white guys
whose biggest issue is...
what, growing up?
- It's... not...
- No, really it's more
nuanced than that.
- It's way more--
- Oh!
- You just hit a woman!
- I apologize for him.
I, for one, would never--
- Oh! Oh, my God!
You hypocrite!
- So I've hit one woman.
That's not-- In the grand--
[retching]
- Ew!
- Welcome, new friends.
- We can all agree
this is a scary cult
and we’re waiting for the other shoe to drop?
We're in a docu-series
and this episode two.
- Dude, completely.
- Yep.
- Insane night!
[mumbling]
Guys, why are we tied up?
- I'd rather die
than live without you boys.
[hawk screeching]
- Holy-!
- Oh!
- Oh, my God!
[screaming]
[hawk shrieking]
- Guys, look.
- Whoa.
- Dude, that's--
that's the treasure door.
- Open it.
[growling]
[screaming]
- What was that?
- Ah!
- I'm gonna be sick.
- I'm gonna be sick
to my stomach.
- Forget the money.
It's not worth it.